[Música]
Bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de medio
ambiente en francés 24 yo soy María
Clara calle estamos usando recursos
biológicos más rápido de lo que la
tierra los produce y cuando hablo de
recursos me refiero por ejemplo a los
alimentos al agua al aire o a la energía
A ese desbalance se le llama sobregiro
que es calculado por la ong de global
foodbrid Network y el hallazgo de este
año es impactante al 28 de Julio la
humanidad ya consumió los recursos que
el planeta se demora todo el año en
general es decir que en 2022 la
humanidad exige la biocapacidad que
producirían 1,75 planetas como la tierra
Pero cómo se llega al cálculo de que en
2022 el 28 de Julio es el día del
sobregiro de la tierra de global
foodbrid Network divide la biocapacidad
del planeta esto es la cantidad de
recursos que la tierra produce en un año
por la huella ecológica que es lo que
demanda y el resultado se multiplica por
365 el número de días de un año cada año
este día llega más pronto en 1971 la
humanidad cruzó por primera vez el
sobregiro y fue el 25 de diciembre en
1991 se adelantó más de dos meses al 13
de octubre y en 2022 ha sido la fecha
más temprana de todas al igual que en
2018 cuando también fue el 28 de Julio
todo este acumulado produce una deuda
ecológica enorme a este punto la
humanidad haya consumido lo que a la
Tierra le tardará 19 años más en
regenerar ahora Hablemos del cálculo por
países el peor en la escala de Singapur
pues sus habitantes necesitarían 104 de
sus países para satisfacer su demanda de
recursos naturales Bélgica por su parte
es el peor rankeado de Europa Pues los
belgas necesitarían hasta 9 veces su
propio país para suplir su demanda de
recursos ecológicos Pro realmente
hablando esto es más de lo que
necesitarían Japón Egipto China o
Estados Unidos en América Latina y el
Caribe los países con más desbalance
entre su biocapacidad y su huella
ecológica son El Salvador República
Dominicana Haití Cuba y Belice el
desbalance entre los recursos que
consumimos los humanos y lo que puede
producir el planeta se debe a todos los
problemas ambientales como la
deforestación la sobreexplotación
agrícola y por supuesto la contaminación
por gases de efecto invernadero Y de
igual manera las soluciones para frenar
el sobregiro son las mismas que ya hemos
escuchado como reducir el desperdicio de
alimentos apostar por la economía
circular y los transportes amigables con
el medio ambiente y alejarse de los
combustibles fósiles y mientras actuamos
en la vida práctica el sobregiro se ve
por ejemplo en la falta de comida y es
que entre menos ecosistemas haya y más
aumente la contaminación crece la
inseguridad alimentaria más de 3
millones de personas viven en países
donde se consumen más alimentos de los
que se producen y el riesgo sube con la
crisis climática como lo evidencian la
sequías en el Nilo el segundo río más
largo del mundo y que atraviesa 11
países africanos al 2040 casi la mitad
de las personas que viven en la Cuenca
del Nilo podrían padecer escasez de agua
por las olas de calor esto impacta a la
agricultura un sector que se vio todavía
más golpeado con la pandemia y con la
guerra en Ucrania Samuel Salgado nos
cuenta lo que están atravesando los
campesinos egipcios
la alimentación de más de 100 millones
de personas puede estar en riesgo en
África y es que el agua es cada vez más
escasa en la cuenca del Río Nilo por la
sequías y las olas de calor extremo el
efecto lo siente con fuerza la
agricultura de Egipto que depende casi
en su totalidad de esas aguas a 30
kilómetros del Cairo estas granjas son
las principales abastecedoras de
productos agrícolas para el consumo
interno del país se ubican en la
provincia de caluvia en pleno delta del
Nilo los productores locales se sienten
desprotegidos por el estado Mohamed a
belmo es dice que la agricultura está
muerta
los pequeños agricultores ya no pueden
comprar nada ni vender sus cosechas Cómo
podemos pagar nuestra renta y
alimentarnos
Mohamed además se queja de que no hay
agua en el Canal de riego lo que retrasa
un día entero la Irrigación de estos
pequeños arrozales e incrementa el costo
Diario del bombeo del motor de riego al
tener que pagar alrededor de 15 dólares
de gasolina sin su trabajo la falta de
trigo debido a la guerra en Ucrania
habría afectado aún más a Egipto según
la Organización de las Naciones Unidas
para la alimentación y la agricultura
FAO solo el 35% de la tierra cultivable
es trabajada por campesinos Mientras que
el 60% del trigo es traído del
extranjero dato que para los productores
refleja y el abandono del Estado egipcio
a la producción interna
algunos campesinos han abandonado su
tierra no la han vendido ni sembrado no
saben qué hacer con ella porque llevan
años perdiendo cualquiera que cultive
cebolla tomate o pimiento no hace
absolutamente ningún beneficio
tres de cada diez agricultores egipcios
son analfabetas por lo que sus
alternativas económicas son escasas
además de hablar de los efectos de la
crisis climática también hay que ver los
efectos de nuestras acciones en
ecosistemas como los manglares esto a
propósito del día internacional de la
conservación de estos ecosistemas que se
celebra el 26 de julio el 60% de los
manglares que se han perdido ha sido por
la mano de los humanos Pues los
destruyeron para urbanizarlos o para
fines agrícolas según global mangle
aliens en las últimas dos décadas Se ha
perdido el 4,3% de estos ecosistemas en
el mundo Aunque la Perdida sea
desacelerado es vital cuidarlos son la
defensa de la costa contra las mareas
los tsunamis y la erosión además una
hectárea de manglar captura 100 veces
más carbono que una hectárea de bosque
tropical y absorbe tanto CO2 como el
equivalente a sacar de circulación a
2.650 vehículos en un año y por último
en algunos países casi todos los
Pescadores a pequeña escala dependen
directamente de los manglares
con ese llamado me despido me pueden
seguir en mis redes sociales que
aparecen en pantalla vean más
información ambiental en francés 24.com
[Música]